when you want to hire people to a
company what kind of people do you want
hire to a company do you just want to
hire anybody to a company or do you want
the best types of talent that comes to
your company you want the top talent you
could possibly get so for me is the
following what I have a problem with
immigration is the following kids who
are growing up in China they're growing
up in Japan they're growing up in
Germany they're growing up in Mexico
Brazil they come to us and they go to a
school wharton harvard USC UCLA pick up
they go to school they come here for
four years they're coming on a student
visa they come here they get their
degree and then what happens to them
they go back to their countries why are
we sending back let me let me get this
straight
you came here we give you our best
training we give you our best education
why are we letting you go back here's
what my system would be you came here
based on good grades yes yes great you
can be paid on your own dime yes or you
got scholarship yes you complete your
four-year degree with a certain GPA you
automatically get a green card to stay
in u.s. why am I losing to bad to good
talent I don't want to lose the talent
course by the way here's another one for
you
you're in America you're an illegal
immigrant right now you broke the law to
come in here you have certain criterias
if you decide to join the military and
surfer this nation that's another way of
getting a green card by the way I joined
the army without citizenship I was in
the US Army with a green card I've got
our June of 99 21st and I got my
citizenship just so you know that I went
in the army with a green card last part
here with when it comes out to
immigration we have to have a filtering
system I went to Panama and I was
playing poker at Panama this was a few
years back and I'm having poker a
playing poker with a senator and we're
having a great time these guys these are
money people if you've never been to
Panama two percent unemployment damn
buildings you've never seen if you pull
up some of the real estate in Panama
type in Panama real estate Panama
skyscrapers or Panama yeah Panama
skyscrapers right there just click on it
this stuff you see in Panama watch this
I've never seen any of this stuff and
you guys never seen a building like that
a u.s. oh look at that building right
there in toilet eternity eternity you've
never seen that if you click on that guy
right there the one right there you
look at that I mean you go to Panama and
you're driving on you're thinking to
yourself how click on the other one the
tallest building in Panama picture right
there right there right there right do
you were just on it no the second one go
one more lower buddy right there it says
talk okay we're gonna work on this guys
you might think that guy is inept and
get it together this is the only thing
he's bad that was amazing at everything
else and it's Panama City I'm talking
about Panama which was it's a twisty
turny woman Skye is are there Norwegian
twisty turny
they can't see it here just so you know
they cannot see you okay they cannot see
it I know Google you can look at the
towers and in buildings in Panama it's
insane but we're playing poker one night
this is not your Vince Vaughn story no
this is that's an amazing a great story
so I'm playing poker with the senator
and then I ask everybody around the
table where are you from Dallas Texas
I'm sorry yeah from Dallas oh you have
any vacation yeah no I live here wait
you live here I live in Panama get out
here yes I said what were you from
Florida why are you in Panama vacation
no I live here
come home man why are you here everybody
at the table we're all from us that are
living in Panama hence if a civil war
ever breaks out of us Panama's a fine
pad
why why yeah why the enema so I see why
are you here why are you here he says
well first of all Panama now you're
gonna get it take a different angle I'm
gonna give you a different angle
they said unemployment low good for
business good life they don't bother you
they're not in your way and if you can
bring 300 thousand dollars into Panama
they give you a green card but you can
live here okay if you bring three
hundred thousand dollars in Panama you
buy a house or you bring $300,000 put in
a bank guess what you get to live you
okay so what what's the pointer I'm
sitting there saying to myself if you
want the best that if you and I decide
to run a country today okay folks in
Seattle decided runs a couple blocks
called what yes
that's the country it's working out say
it's definitely working out yeah so if
we decided to run our own country
okay if we decide to run our own country
and you are the president
we are your advisers what kind of
immigrants do you want to attract to
your country Adam I want the best I want
the brightest I want the most talented
of the richest oh what a peach he sounds
like a bigot you buddy which you just
said right there
Wow you what you just said that's
offensive because you just absolutely
violated immigration because you only
want the best that is not fair bro why
would you build your entry line this
isn't this is a Sean Hannity guy right
bring me your mouth is this all about
one was the last shame on you but I want
talented people mine's coming
ethnic if you're gonna start a company
don't you want the smart are you the
ones debating with me but I'm not trying
to tell you is the fact that which you
just said makes sense but politicians in
America are fighting that they're
fighting it America should have a system
where the best at the best of the best
in the world want to come to America and
ours I don't buddy we don't have that
system right now so the filtering system
needs to have a better criteria but can
I say something
if you meet this if you meet this if you
meet this you want the best obviously we
want the best the brightest the most
talented companies like you Adam we're
gonna also help people that are
struggling like you gave the example of
the father who came here illegally did
you not mmm
the father who came here illegally is
worried about his daughter's getting
raped he did break the law go okay he
did break the law that's I'm okay if he
gets caught he should get arrested well
yeah I mean arrested okay I'll go back
home but that happens every day but I
would still do it is what I'm trying to
[Music]